- I'm like, "Why are
you driving so fast?
There's all these people up
there crossing the street."
She was like, "You pussies
in black flag always talk
about the end of the
world and destruction,
the destruction starts now.
We're gonna kill all
these fuckin' people."
- Welcome to This
Is Not Happening,
I'm your host Ari Shaffir.
- This'll fucking do man.
- [Ari] It's just a
bunch of funny people
telling like 100% true stories.
- The fuck is wrong with you?
- And tonight the
topic is psychedelia,
Karma, nostalgia,
melee, bloodline,
disaster,crime, romance.
- Just a yarn about
how I stuck my dick
where it shouldn't have gone.
- Not my babies...
- Do you understand the
predicament that you are in?
No.
(laughter)
- Yeah man, I didn't
want to do it,
but you know, they
were all yelling so,
fuck it man, cut zero off and...
- I aint gonna go see that, no.
- We just legalized gay
marriage in this country,
don't take a step back
on dog homosexuality.
- We're snorting Ritalin
and eating mushrooms,
and then we decide,
"You know what? Let's
just steal the car.
Let's steal the car."
- I think we get
to suck your tits.
Yeah, we get to suck your tits.
- I'm gonna make you cum,
I gonna make you cum so hard.
And I'm just like, "Uh, yeah
buddy, whenever you want."
- Yeah.
- You can't eat pizza
that's not real.
(laughter)
Okay.
- I'm gonna burn
my sister to death,
I'm naked and my
boyfriend's screaming.
- I am no different than Christ.
- 'Cos if you just thought,
"I'm shitting in
Nancy Grace's mouth,"
then you can keep going.
- You're my lawyer.
- I think my vagina's too small.
I think your dick is too big.
- So we, out of paranoia...
I got hooked on crack.
I mean, I got hooked on crack.
- I had become a part
of the talent show.
My talent...
Shitting everywhere.
- She pulls a butcher knife
from the back of her skirt.
- And she looks me
right in the eye
and I swear to God she says,
'I want you to cum on my face."
- He doesn't speak Spanish.
- And I don't know
what the hell I hit,
but blood went everywhere.
- Your mind can't
even wrap its head
around what's happening.
- Can I buy you fellas
another round of drinks?
Holy shit, I'm not getting
stabbed for $12 an hour.
- She's looking at
a pig driving a car
doing cocaine.
- Let's go.
- I'm not into no
Goddamn gay shit.
I got a wife, I got a
family, and you're too young.
- Holy Spirit went to a court
and figured out how
to sue somebody.
And he sued me.
He sued me $800 million dollars.
God, $800 million dollars.
(applause)